speaking of hitting homeruns which one
of my jokes you're gonna quote nope none
of them Star Wars has made another
announcement oh cool
I hope it's another one they are they
die they're doing episode 9 oh [ __ ]
because somehow in all these new Star
Wars movies that have come out we have
not yet gotten a full trilogy how many
Star Wars movies have there been 71
right and we haven't completed the third
trilogy Tracy my fader has a mall job in
this one I [ __ ] hate it
Darth sheperson it just stinks it's too
much franchise stinks
I mean Travis you even think it's too
much now right I'm looking forward this
one everyone 9 yeah because it continues
to cool those little fat furry things
you watch rocks you just jumped on it
huh
Oh literal test someone got excited
what's next [ __ ] what's this next soon
to bomb film no well we'll see
absolutely well solo is supposed to be
pretty big ever solo as a contained
story this is what this one's over so 10
also episode 8 people did not like it no
they're all old now what happens the
Jedi does something Billy Dee what's
going on Billy Dee Williams is coming
back oh yeah finally for episode 9
because you know after 40 years you
wonder get that guy back in the movie
right
I interviewed Billy Dee Williams a few
years ago yeah how was he I met him once
he had literally was like it was like
talking with statue yeah I wouldn't
electric is not the word I would use for
him now yeah isn't he slightly
unpleasant he wasn't the most pleasant
and also he didn't like to answer
questions which made the interview a
long one right no I did not
well look there's only been 38 years
since the last one so let's see what
this next what's the new one called
what's it what's the name of it the
force what the Jedi what I don't know it
just has Star Wars Episode nine right
now I don't know I don't think they have
an official title so what is it it's the
new hope
featuring oh wait I forgot
we got a start episode 1 episode 1 is
what's the name of episode 1 Travis
Phantom Menace the faint right with
Darth Maul oh it's cool name the fancy
lost people and [ __ ] [ __ ] nonsense
[ __ ] George Jefferson yeah [ __ ]
dog
how about dog kick-ass look that's cool
yes hole Phantom Menace and then attack
of the clones yes Revenge of the Sith
what's a sip it's a villain rise or a
Sith Lord
yeah Sith Lord of course a new hope yeah
compression Empire Strikes Back Return
of the Jedi
that's right Return of the Jedi and then
what was the seventh one the Jedi's
mother's [ __ ] no force awakens
oh yeah the force awakens more about the
force house the more that you know
what's the next one after that the next
one after that is what last Jedi cool
Jedi force force Jedi we heard you right
the last you got it and then who knows
horse Jedi Oh but JJ Abrams is back to
directing this one is that right and
writing you alright you know what a
little bit more faith with that cuz I
like JJ Abrams and episode 7 was pretty
good it was the same as episode 4 yeah
of course it was how so was the same
movie Oh ball plot points were exactly
the same yeah that's fair I never think
of it that way but by the way everybody
loved it is the last Jedi good about
Luke it depends on who you ask people
did not like the way a lot of people who
hated it because people are tired of
this thing it's using and it's upside
down it was confused topsy-turvy
it's topsy-turvy a circular here's a
standalone one that you are and this is
a new one this part ain't you [ __ ] you
yeah make a bunch of movies in a row you
know what the good one was yeah the
first one and the second one and the
third one this turbine was okay those
Ewoks Duncan hated the Ewoks
I hated them you like rogue one yes I
did that was one way the planner blows
up yeah but you know it's at the end it
was great that way yeah that was a good
one
yes sorry so three and forty years I
apologize it is way too much with the
Star Wars Christ endless gotta make
their money what are you talking about
Disney's gotta make their money they're
making their money exactly I paid a lot
for that franchise look Disney's got
every TV network
they got all Marvel they got all Star
Wars they get their own Disney movies
they got the Pixar movies and they got
some theme parks somewhere making money
don't they yeah they're doing pretty
good yeah they're fine they don't see
art up they don't need a Star Wars movie
every year it all started with a mouse
it did yeah and an anti-semitic
illustrator there's a rumor now I don't
know how true that is
I don't know it's a rumor I've heard so
room yeah what do you think Travis do I
think he outsourced Ravi's animators do
propaganda films mm-hmm by the way if he
was if he was anti-semitic it would
explain why Travis wears a Disney shirt
every day oh my god without a doubt yeah
Oh his knee holding this old mother
Steelers absolutely yeah they control
the medium they steal your mother what
he's just starting new stereotypes
they're like pennies and mothers even a
neo-nazi rally Travis says something
about them stealing mothers never turns
and looks at him like we talking about
your mother on the ground see if they
pick it up yeah this is a weird a weird
neo-nazi cuz he doesn't hate blacks or
gays he only hates Jews and only Jewish
males right because their mother's
Steelers a mother only rabbis let's
steal your mother there but they're
their mommy thieves steal you a mummy
leave a boy home sad is that what you
like Disney so much yep makes me forget
vengeance yeah just a little I get it
they really though it's a lot of [ __ ]
franchise enough also they don't need to
do any more Jurassic park's well I gotta
stop I mean they gotta finish the
trilogy at least Jurassic Park we know
is a bunch of dumb dinosaurs and it's
all graphics it was right we show the
first one to my daughter dress her part
over break yeah that movie still holds
up Jurassic Park is awesome great
[ __ ] good
Jurassic world is a good movie - was
that the first one with Chris Pratt yeah
that's good it's good the new one how
many are there five Ian Malcolm in
Jurassic Park the lost world Jurassic
Park 3 Jurassic world and then whatever
this one was called The Land Before Time
yep that's it
ok they yeah neither all like weird you
know the [ __ ] velociraptor driving a
cab dude stupid no a lot of people are
critical of I believe the ending of
Jurassic Park 3 when the Raptor says
Alan it's maybe one of the worst
decisions made saddest tree have you
ever seen it no okay Troy YouTube
Jurassic Park 3 Alan yeah what's the
guy's name Alan yes it was watch this
now technically this is a dream sequence
Wow all right but it's just the way it's
displayed on on film
Oh was that bad
wow you took a lot of steam out of the
Raptors sales that's terrible
oh honey I don't even know is it
something else sock puppet is it
somebody's voice from the film no it's a
guy oh look my favorite it ruins
everything
it literally ruined it ruined Citizen
Kane just stop making films after this
there he is
dr. Allen is waking up from his nap on a
plane Alan that's not scary it's
horrible imagine if you had that dream
like I said the weirdest [ __ ] dream
Raptor he just talked like a person and
he went it would have been more
realistic if the Raptor said who the
[ __ ] is flying this plane
that's awful hey it's me and you who the
[ __ ] flying this thing how did that
make it into the edit I don't know man
how do people make fun of that the
minute it happened the minute and every
minute sense Wow I mean it's been
decades if making fun of that one is
very 2001 yeah that movies that old huh
Jurassic Park 3 yeah yeah the first ones
25 years old now doggie Cyrus but I
thought you were around play 5
he wakes up and finds Edgar the rafter
next to him oh no it's a raptor and he's
mad where's the Raptor rappers got
razor-sharp teeth but he keeps licking
them for some reason I don't know why he
just wakes up he sees a raptor and the
Raptor looks right at him and goes oh
[Laughter]
it's one of those decisions that's
really bad that you just looked at and
you cannot believe that I made it to the
premiere right that's somebody what
that's great
who signed off on that where they were
like yeah this works just having the
thing in there is it bad enough so to
say that's a terrible decision and
clearly ream like every part of it too
is bad part of it is the voice that they
use the whole thing let's watch it again
the mouth opens up like a like a
literally like a sock puppet right oh oh
and he wakes up right after oh that's
right
it's poorly shot very poorly shot this
scene is poorly shot looks fake okay I'm
on a plane alone nobody Whitney no pilot
oh no island that is [ __ ] hideous do
you think that they were watching that
how did that make it improve the actors
saw that in the premiere because they
wouldn't have seen that scene play out
all they would have seen is a raptor
puppet in an airplane set but they still
would have said he's gonna say your name
Alan and they just look at red [ __ ]
watch it those watch what's the scene
play out and they go oh no that's really
bad what have we got the rest of the
actors who weren't there hey by the way
can we get a copy of the Jurassic world
3 script can we see if that part was
actually in the script yeah yeah I'll
look forward today for tomorrow yeah
let's look it up